the faa is proposing the largest fines
ever against two passengers for unruly
behavior one of them was on a flight out
of las vegas it happened last july the
faa says the woman tried to hug and kiss
another passenger then tried exiting the
plane she's also accused of biting
another passenger the faa has proposed a
77 thousand dollar fine
in fact in all of 2021 the faa launched
more than a thousand investigations into
passengers disrupting flights in many
cases those people will get physically
verbally abusive towards pilots and the
flight crew
current laws allow passengers to ban i
should say allow airlines to ban
passengers but it doesn't stop them from
finding a different carrier and that's
why many are in support of a universal
no-fly list that airlines can share
it's been way overdue and
we need to just get this done so that we
can protect the our passengers our crew
members and the safety of our skies if
you're going to disrupt the operation of
the crew then you will no longer fly on
airlines anymore
an attempt to pass a federal no-fly list
was cut short back in february when
several republican senators pushed back
they said it would equate unruly
passengers to terrorists and would bar
them from their constitutional right to
freely travel